so David what was it about Hellraiser
that made you decide I'm gonna remake A
beloved franchise
well uh there was an appetite to do it I
mean as a fan I just have always thought
it's a a really expansive palette to
play in and um there's just universes
you can do with this world and so
um when Spyglass had gotten behind it
and Phantom 4 and um approached Ben and
Luke uh the writers and then myself
um you know it felt like you know an
amazing opportunity to open that door
and
um uh I mean I never thought I'd had the
opportunity to work on a Hellraiser
movie but as a as a filmmaker of horror
uh it's something of a dream come true
and it's fun it's crazy it's challenging
in every imaginable way which is really
a testament to those earlier films like
when you get into it you you realize how
dense and layered the material real is
both in its themes and ideas but also
just in the Practical creation of it
it's Quite a feat why a remake or a
reboot instead of another installment in
the franchise well I think that it was
difficult to sort of trace it in a uh as
canon in any sort of strict regard and
um I I feel like there's such a spirit
of invention in the original film that
to me
um sticking in some sort of very very
strict way to the events that had been
played out across many many sequels was
honestly
Less in the spirit of the original which
was this uh bold vision of something new
that wasn't afraid of where it would go
and um and then I've also always been a
fan of you know I mean how do we regard
rip you know I I like a little bit of
what DC has done over the years where
every few years somebody gives you a
different take on a popular character
and you go like I didn't know I was down
for you know an emo Batman Detective of
until Matt Reeves showed it to us and
there's a piece of me that goes like
yeah what if what if this is Batman and
you play that game for a period of time
and this will not be the last Hellraiser
movie but this is our Hellraiser movie
and this this was the direction we were
most inspired to take it Jamie was there
any anxiety about stepping into a role
as beloved as a pinhead
copious amount
I mean you know I think that what the
the goal that we had wasn't for me you
know to mimic any performance that had
been done before you know I mean Doug is
Iconic no one can you know fill those
you know gorgeous blood soaked shoes you
know they're too big to fill
um so David and I just had many
conversations you know about what what
you know this version would be and what
she would look like and what she would
sound like and what her motivations were
and I really just tried you know to take
everything that we talked about in those
conversations and then bring that with
me into the makeup trailer and then you
know once the makeup was all done just
kind of like
melt all of those things together to the
you know to then when I when I got on to
set I was just really mentally in this
um incredibly dark sensual place that I
had never been before that was a really
fun trip
um a place to explore as an actor that
was so fun and I mean I just I just hope
that people like it
was the goal going in to to create a
female Pinhead or was it just that Jamie
was the best for the role regardless of
gender
we always knew we we wanted to we wanted
Pinhead to be played by a woman we um
but we didn't know how to do that we
didn't know who would do that and uh it
was Jamie's read that struck us
um she was absolutely terrifying but she
also had a kind of transfixing quality
that I couldn't ignore and there's so
much of Hellraiser is the tension of I
don't want to look at this but I have to
you know and
um there was just something hypnotic
about the way she was taking the words
and I think instantly working with her
and callbacks and talking through the
process I was just enthralled because it
to me I felt like her take on it was a
path forward so here's a way to play the
priest that is not
um an imitation of what doug did is you
know as she was saying it's uh it's
taking it in different directions but
it's opening up Corners the character
that I hadn't imagined and um you know
she's curious
um she's there there's something you can
lean into she's quite threatening and
dangerous but at the same time if you
can win her affections and impress her
in the white right way as a matter of
taste you may end up in a better
situation you don't really know and I I
thought that was really intriguing yeah
she's not an out and out villain
you know did you did you see her in that
way did you play her in that way Jamie
it's well it's it's interesting I mean
no I mean because the cenobites don't
ask you know to to be summoned you know
we just are we're showing up and we're
doing our job and we're doing it to the
best of our ability and and our job just
entails these certain tasks that it
might be unsavory to some but we're
really just trying to show these people
who are playing with the box that you
know there's so much more and it's come
listen it's right over here come on so
no she's not in villain am I the villain
I think we were we were always drawn to
the idea in the original film that they
were somewhat neutral there's always a
more morally corrupt human figure
um and that the cinebites are offering
experience but it's experience to a
particular extremity that uh you may or
may not want to partake in depending on
your tastes and and that's where the
tension comes from okay and I just have
to ask now that
um Disney owns 21st Century Fox uh
Pinhead is now technically a Disney
princess what do you say to that
loves it bring it on where's my tiara
we're waiting for the ride
um at Disneyland uh the Labyrinth it's
uh
uh not not not for the kids for adults
only adults yes okay great well thank
you guys so much I really appreciate it
thank you so much